there is absolutely uh i'm a hundred
percent certain
that this is a hundred percent another
ponzi scheme that you're getting into
and i find it fascinating that you're
like that you've gone
from one coin don't forget
now you're doing cuban tech stop dude
but you're addicted to it i want to
believe
ladies and gentlemen i have a hell of an
episode for you today this
is a weird interview because i didn't
know what the story was
going into the interview and i sort of
found out what was the most interesting
part
halfway through the story so who you're
gonna listen to today is
mark nishiyama who is someone who
contacted me
to blow the whistle on this ponzi scheme
right
but upon calling him i slowly realized
this is not the only ponzi scheme
mark has been involved in and as i find
out more i realize that this is a guy
who's addicted to these ponzi schemes he
keeps going from one ponzi scheme
to another and then now he was coming on
the show allegedly to
tell people to not invest in what what
are called hypes
you couldn't invent a a more fitting
name right
for all the hype uh high yield
investment program is what that stands
for and they're always ponzi schemes
right
that are promising these incredible you
know gains and people end up losing
their shirts on them
because they think they're gonna make a
lot of money and then it ends up
crashing and burning and no one gets
paid
so he comes on the show to tell people
not to do that but come to find out
after the interview was closing i'm
closing up the interview thanks mark for
coming on
he tells me that he hasn't actually
given up on hypes himself
like he's once again going into another
scam
and that's when i realized that this
this whole show
was much more about mark than it was
about the individual
program he was scammed by and it's
almost more of a character study of a
person who is addicted
to ponzi schemes and i know for a fact
mark isn't the only one because back
when i was investigating futurenet i
found another guy who said oh yeah this
isn't my first
scam that i've been a part of i've been
ripped off several times before
in like a very similar crypto ponzi
scheme and my thought was when reading
that like
well why didn't you learn your lesson
and i always wanted to understand the
psychology behind that
but this was my first opportunity to
actually talk to somebody
who cannot stop believing and investing
in these insane
scams and so yeah i
found it fascinating talking to mark i
really appreciate him coming on most
people would be scared to be
this transparent um but i think you guys
will find mark a
complex fascinating individual
and not entirely sympathetic but not
entirely unsympathetic
i'm interested i'm really interested in
hearing what you guys
think about this show because it's
unlike many of our shows
where the point of the interview is the
point of the interview in this one
it's the point of the entire interview
in my mind the more interesting part
is sort of the psychology of mark
and so i wonder what you guys think let
me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this one and uh
i'll see you next time welcome to copies
of look guys today we have
mark nishiyama is that right yeah you
got it right
i'm doing my best mark you lost over
a hundred thousand dollars in a
what seems to me to be a ponzi scheme
but we'll get into it
uh and i'd like you to just start off
with the company how you got involved
and um
yeah just walk us through kind of a
little bit of backstory before we dive
into this
sure yeah thank you for having me on um
yeah we were all introduced to alcor
about
uh four months ago uh my
good friend from another company that we
did cryptocurrency together
uh introduced it to me and he just
introduced me to his
upline name alex i'm not sure that's his
real name i have a photo of the guy
but um you know he would come on
webinars with a face mask and say it's
corona so
i can't show my face but i have a photo
of the guy yeah
right dude give me a break dude what a
liar
i'm gonna catch your corona through the
screen no dude this guy
this guy knew what he was doing all
right yeah
like number one already in the bank yeah
so uh they promised uh
daily payouts of one to three percent
depending on your deposit amount so i
started off
paying in at about three hundred dollars
and just to test the system and
it did pay out they paid out you know
two percent and
you know every day we could withdraw the
amount you know in bitcoin
so obviously we increased the amount
thousand dollars
five thousand ten thousand eventually we
put in
more you know like i sold all my stocks
you know apple stock to to put more
money in
over a hundred thousand usd
uh and uh
it after the maturity of 30 days or 30
working days which is a month and a half
the deposit does come back but most
people reinvest it so
a lot of us you know we lost big amounts
of money in my group
alone about seven million dollars total
so the the whole scheme of alcor betting
company
slow down your group so to back up
you have a history with mlms right yes
yes i've been in mlm for about 20 years
okay you probably know my opinion of mlm
but that's fine
but um mlm uh so you added like a whole
sort of what do you call it team or like
what what do you all
refer to it as it's not a lot upline or
download
a group you can just group yeah a group
that kind of came with you and you you
had um
mentioned right before this i don't know
if it was during the recording
uh that previously y'all had just had
something go bust can you tell me
and so people were looking to get their
money back
yeah we were in this other
cryptocurrency company for about
four years and you know they promised
that we go public and we never did so i
what
what was that company uh
it starts with a o and
it has this coin so that's one guy in
this one
it's one of the famous ones out there
it's hard for me to say
yeah because it's still going it's still
ongoing as well
how much do you think you lost in one
coin uh
it about 300 000
maybe around there of over four years
yeah around there yeah and you were
basically looking to get back on your
feet reset
things yes you're gonna get it back fast
is what we've tried to do you know
recover the loss
so this look really you know exciting
because three percent per day
you know times 30 days is 90
if you keep compounding your interest
instead of taking it out
you could basically get uh you know
double your money in in 40 days you know
now i have to ask you does that
sound suspicious to you though that like
that is
you know the too good to be true thing
yeah
it obviously sounds too good to be true
in the beginning you know because that's
why you put small amounts in but you
know it pays out in the beginning
and the whole scheme of alcor bidding
company was that they were
a bookmaker they had the bookmaking
license they're they're the house
basically
like like a casino so they were like did
gambling bets and stuff like that
is what you're saying right right and
they use our money to
take on more bets the more bets they can
take on the more money they will make
because
bookmakers always make money and they're
sharing the profit one to three percent
per day it makes sense right
because they probably make 10 20 per day
so they share one to three percent it's
not that much okay
it's good it makes sense everybody
bought into it you know it's really easy
to sell i mean
i don't want to say that i'm a
good salesman but it was not that
difficult you know because
everybody wanted to get on and they
could see their daily results
so when it started to get you know uh
toward the end
we saw some strange things like the
payments supposed to come out every
you know every day at 3 p.m japan time
it would be a little bit late like 3 45
you know four o'clock
and some of my um members had their
coins actually stolen from their
accounts and they said it was hackers
but i had a feeling that was
people in the company actually like
taking out deposits when they say
accounts do they mean it was the were
the accounts hosted on alcor's betting
thing yes on the billing platform oh 100
it was the
owners yeah so you know when they
stopped the
withdrawals when we couldn't take out
the money they would say oh don't worry
we're just revamping the system
this is thursday june 30th they're
revamping the system
getting a new exchange on the on the
blockchain etc
and everything's gonna be fine by sunday
so we come sunday
you know we're waiting three days still
no and these
type of hype hyip high yield investment
programs normally when they stop playing
they don't pay anymore i mean that's the
end
oh 100 the ponzi scheme has collapsed uh
yeah i think i i mentioned earlier but i
think hype is the perfect name for these
because it's
yeah they're all actually if but you can
call it hype yes hyip yeah yeah
um so at the end you know on monday when
they said it would everything
be fixed they you know oh you know i was
in daily contact with the company the
cfo
scott allen brown could have been alan
brown it could have been
georgie rozinski we don't know okay i
mean
we're in contact every day and with
support they're really good so the
support was
spot on i mean they would come back with
replies immediately
you know not like other companies but
anyway on monday
you know four days after the withdrawal
stop they shut down the account
you know it's you know four zero four
not found that that was it and yeah
everybody
ran oh yeah
so you know there's some people that
i don't know if they're the real names i
want them to know that i'm
following up on them alex mack ethan
james
willem cooper that's not his name
probably um
is it copper it looks like copper to me
yeah it looks like copper
could be cooper or copper okay yeah
but he had an eastern european accent i
don't know why we fell for it you know
people would say oh he's an immigrant
but and there was another company that
failed the next week called
four rise and they kind of had the same
timing about six seven months
and it ended and uh i mean these are all
things are all
ponzi schemes like even your description
of oh yeah it worked at first
that's how ponzi schemes work is they
pay out to give the appearance of
legitimacy
um and especially at the low numbers it
makes sense right like oh i'm putting in
300 i'm getting back whatever
they don't mind paying that back but
they're never gonna like
once you told me that you put in i think
how much did you lose total like a
hundred thousand dollars of your own
money
uh well actually
about uh 24 bitcoin my own money
24. oh my gosh that just
hurts to that hurt that's painful
23 bitcoin yes
that is about 11 000 no
260 dollars total uh yes that's with 23
bitcoin i try not to think about it
let's put it that way
you've got to think about it because you
you got
this is the second time in a row these
are huge losses
you guys uh you know
are you done just be honest are you done
with crypto you should be done with
crypto at this point
well i'm done with ico crypto okay i'm
still collecting bitcoin obviously
for ethereum but the the new ones that
think they can be the next bitcoin
amount for sure right right what about
these uh
hype are you out of the hypes i'm out
yeah it's easier to find a hype i mean
they just promise more than it's
possible and they
you don't know the people behind it you
just there's so many out there
and you know it's really easy to fall
for and i guess
you know the purpose of coming on your
your
channel is is to warn people that you
know there's no easy
there's no shortcuts you know to wealth
no you need to
really really dig in like i saw your
other youtube video with that guy who
you know does real estate you know he's
like 23 but
he has you know passive income of 38 000
it's good
so if everyone can you know know about
hype and just stay away from it
you know it's so tempting because the
returns are so good
and the people that promote it as well
you know are making money so you think
you can do that as well
you know and they disappear as well when
the company goes bust
because they don't want to take any
responsibility for
all the losses as well but you know
for me i have some people that you know
trust me and follow me so
i'm still trying to find you know the
next best thing
oh no don't say that wait what is what
is the next best
thing don't say that something that's
safer that's something that's safer
anyway
you know at least we know who the people
are there
but you know there is no 100 perfect
investment out there anyway so but
that's true but there are investments
that are actual opportu like for example
there are investments that are actually
doing what they say they're doing and
then there are people like alcor who
never had any kind of betting going on
they just said that as a cover story for
their ponzi scheme
uh right so you could actually bet on
their platform though and they'd pay you
if you win
and they're actual matches but it was
never enough to cover
all the profits that they claimed that
they have of course
the same with uh i don't know if you
followed the future net story
they had a whole thing about they were
selling ad packs or whatever
and it's all a cover story for how
they're made they're actually making
their money
so that's what i mean is those are
investments that they're literally
lying about what the investment is the
investment is a ponzi scheme
uh but there are investments like like
you said real estate
you can invest in real estate it's not
risk-free but
you're actually doing the thing that
you're allegedly doing does that make
sense and you have something you know
tangible that
will be there you know even if the
market goes down yes
now let me ask you about um multi-level
marketing
real quick if we can detour real quick
don't you think that's kind of
also sort of a a scam industry the whole
premise is like a is like basically it's
just a pyramid scheme and the guys at
the top just like everything else are
the winners and the guys at the bottom
are the losers like just like this okay
well um
you know this time alcor was an
affiliate marketing system whereas
you know you would get you know
bonuses based on the deposits of the
people that you brought in
and it would be direct to you okay mlm
is multi-level
so it's usually binary where you have
one leg which is your power leg one leg
that's your paling
and whatever volume comes in as far as
it goes it goes all the way to the top
to you but you know
to give you some history you know mlm
was created by
apparently a harvard professor who
wanted to bridge the gap between
the rich and poor in a capitalist
society because in capitalism you need
capital
so with a small investment say 500 or 1
000
there is a possibility that you do make
a million dollars
if you have a good sponsor if you have a
good company you get in at the right
time there's all kinds of factors that
will help you
but um you know if you
started a restaurant you know you're
talking hundreds of thousands of dollars
you're in debt
if it goes bust then you're in a bigger
debt so the
investment is small and that's good and
bad because
if it's small you won't lose too much
but on the other hand you won't be in it
a hundred percent if the investment is
small
you know your ass is not on the line
basically so there's plus and minus and
i believe in mlm it's not really a ponzi
because
someone below you can make more money
than you the way most of them are
structured so
it depends on your efforts is is my
opinion of it
yeah but you're always covered like
you're always making money
from someone getting suckered into the
system who
by just how the payout structure works
is probably not gonna make their money
back
i mean i think you've seen all the
different compensation plans and what
they actually pay out
and it's only like two percent of the
people who ever make their money back so
when you go out and you're trying to
make your money back
you're getting someone in the system
almost by definition who's
super likely not to make their money so
in order to not be a sucker you have to
sucker someone else
whereas with like a restaurant someone
pays for food
you make money but they get fed it's
like a it's a
both people are winning here it seems
like one person is winning
and then a lot of people underneath them
are losing in order for them to win big
it seems like doesn't that feel like
what's going on with i mean it's
obviously not the exact same but
doesn't it feel like that's what's going
on with william copper he's winning big
but he's winning big because everyone
else is losing big
that's the alcor betting company ceo by
the
way
they shut down the company with
everybody's bitcoin still in there
so they took in a lot of money you know
some of these
hypes take in 10 per day and then
you know when they they see the the
profits coming down you know the
deposits coming down and the
you know payouts going up they shut it
down but they shut it down
when bitcoin was about up 20 percent so
they
they thought okay we don't need to pay
these people anymore and they shut it
down so
seven months and it was done so yeah
they did they did clear everybody out it
was
it's huge and we don't know where these
people are today
that's that's insane seven million
dollars disappeared like that just in my
group too
how many groups were there how much do
you think was actually totally invested
in this
this uh hype as it were they were giving
us numbers that
they have 400 000 members
okay something like that but i think
that's a little bit overblown i would
say
i would say they probably had close to
maybe 50 000
you know and everybody if they average
put in one bitcoin that's
a lot of bitcoin 50 000 bitcoin you know
do you think that's a good reasonable i
mean how many people did you have in
your group for example
let's just calculate it that way yeah
actually i had about 250
okay so 250 and you're saying that uh
50 000 were invested
that's a lot you all had a lot invested
for millions with 250 people
so there's like okay so there's about
200 groups
similar size to yours and then uh 200
times
7 million
oh my gosh we could go close to a
billion
they could have a billion dollars
this is just not right yeah it's a well
if they if they invested similarly if
those numbers are right they
are running away with roughly a billion
for a billion and four hundred thousand
four hundred million dollars
yeah that's that's total possible that's
a total possibility
yes definitely doesn't that just sting
that's so much money just to steal for
people
it's a lot yeah it is and uh i mean are
you not
dude if somebody just stole a hundred
thousand dollars for me or 250 000
i don't know i'm a pretty harmless guy
but i would say i'd be uh
enraged and
like it's an emotional rollercoaster
after something you know
like this happens you know you go
through anger you go through remorse you
go
denial grief denial brief you go through
everything you know
it's an up and down every day yeah
that's like that
that is horrendous are you i mean are
you okay that's a lot of money
is that like did that wipe you out or
well i also teach financial education
okay
and i tell everyone uh
to always invest
only ten percent of your expendable
cash okay i tell it to people however
you know every time something like this
happens and
you know it's the second time anyway in
my experience people tell me oh marxon
i use my money for my kids education
and i'm like don't tell me that you know
or
i use my money for my husband's funeral
don't tell me that you know it's like i
told you guys just use
ten percent of your expendable cash so
is that what you did
you you just used two percent of your
expenses yeah
sure it's an investment so yeah i
understand so mlm's been good to you
you must be winning with mlm it's been
nice yes
and we're the other one we were in four
years was this was quite
quite good yes which what mlm was that
well
the cryptocurrency that didn't go public
a one coin yes so you made a lot of
money with onecoin
we did okay we were a big leader and we
traveled the world you know
um it's still going on so
there there's a lot of opinions out
there and um
to be honest they could have actually
gone public with it
in the second year but
the the the founder went
you know as a fugitive and she she ran
away
with a lot of money and a lot of things
happened
okay in that company after that one
i was really down and about for about
six months
as well and then we found alcohol and we
thought this was the next best thing
and then this happened as well these are
just parties
one coin was a hundred percent a ponzi
scheme and you went from ponzi scheme to
ponzi scheme
yeah well it's probably because ponzi
scheme one treated you pretty well
and pot well until it kind of was like
uh you know stuck you in the back
at the end but um that's what they
always do
of course right now let me ask you
because i do have to ask because
actually
i encountered a similar guy in futurenet
this guy
do you know who ryan conley is no
anyway it doesn't matter the point is is
he sort of was like you where he had
this group of people who were kind of
like they were
they were a group and they kind of
followed each other around
okay now my thought was this
could ryan connolly have known that
future net was a ponzi scheme
not necessarily but yeah maybe he should
have
i was like i asked him you know do you
take responsibility for the people whose
money was lost because you kind of
brought them in
now i want to ask you the same question
do you feel some sort of
i'm not not saying you're william copper
by any means but do you feel like kind
of
did you were kind of the main person who
brought him in
yeah i feel bad that people lost money
especially the people that i know
close you know the people who spent
their funeral expenses or whatever you
were saying the examples you were having
you know i told you guys not to do that
but you did it anyway but i still feel
bad that's why i'm doing this
uh you know interview
right now you want you want to warn
people stay out of this stuff
oh yeah don't bother yeah
it seems easy and it will seem
like the next best thing you know next
to
cookie dough but it's not
it's it's a scam and it can stop at any
time
and if you introduce people to it and it
does stop
and it will stop you know they will lose
money as well
very well said very well said um
let me think is that that's most of the
story huh
that's like yeah that's most of the
story let me ask you
kind of what our next steps obviously
you probably got to go through your
five stages of grief on this one too
when did this happen
like just recently yeah the company uh
shut down
on august 3rd so it's been three
three four weeks almost a month now wow
that's horrendous you know i've heard
people even commit suicide when these
things happen have you ever heard of
that
oh yeah yeah in in the other crypto
company yes i've heard of that and i've
heard
people actually getting uh
murdered for selling that coin to other
people
i heard about are you talking about the
mexico case yeah
sinaloa yeah smart people you know
to sell to right geez tell everybody
what happened well i
it's it's an article everybody i think
read but i mean they
the uh distributors sold these one coin
packages
to probably the cineloa cartel people
you know mafia
and they got angry because they couldn't
get their money back
yeah and they were found stuffed inside
of a suitcase
right but it's not sorry it's not
something to laugh about it's horrendous
no it's not yeah but
yeah it happens i mean that's a very
dangerous area to be
that's horrible can you tell us any uh
stories from your days in multi-level
mark any kind of crazy story you have
from like
either i know there's a lot of money
going around with the founders there's a
lot of crazy stories with people
running from companies do you have any
good uh stories since you've been in the
industry so long
yeah um i have actually a video
out on how to choose the best mlm
company um
and basically what i talk about is when
you look at a company
it's better to look at the track record
and see how long
they've been running for and if you
don't do that you know you know they're
a new company okay
some people like new companies because
the new companies you know you get in at
the top and stuff like that
so you know i think a lot of companies
that i've seen that
came and failed like monavie which was
selling the acai berry juice
that was a huge company they did
something like
70 million sales in in the first year
and uh it died it died because they
sponsored an
indy car driver called sato takuma
and the car driver you said yeah indy
car
indy car okay 500 million they borrowed
money from
to do just to sponsor this guy i don't
so you know
management you know especially if they
come from a networking background does
not know what they're doing a lot of
times
and there's just crazy things like this
it seems like it seems like
networking management always comes from
networking people who had been in the
industry and gotten scared they're like
i'll do it now i want to be at the top
so they start their own company
hype it up get all their people in on it
and then but they
don't know nothing about management they
don't know how to manage a company and
it usually goes poof
you know and a lot of people get burned
because they lose their money
okay one more thing i wanted to make
clear is that the industry now is so um
the mlm industry is so tainted now by
these
finance-based mlms where they promise to
return
and it's just more attractive than just
buying cosmetics or
you know i did a coffee uh
mlm or or supplements you know but
the basis of mlm is you know tupperware
or
or some item that you buy and you get
some kind of
product yeah but now they're just
selling money
or this ponzi scheme and it's just so
much easier and it's just
there's there's so many out there and
it's turning so fast the industry is
just
a mess right now in my opinion yeah
i mean i would encourage anyone who uh
is interested in or wants to know more
about mlms to turn onto
there's some great math that was done by
i forget his name
it was uh
robert taylor i believe from the
and he did an ftc report on emma on the
math behind him a limbs
um or there's another one about like oh
john taylor excuse me
the case for and against multi-level
marketing that's a really interesting
uh read if you guys want to go check
that out but uh
i'll leave a link down below but i do
think that
multi-level marketing it's it always has
suffered that problem that's always been
the accusation right is that this is not
actually selling a product
it's selling it's selling a dream and
what you're saying is
right now that feels actually to be the
truth that people are more and more just
leaving
the tupperware days behind and they're
just consist always going towards
you know the hype the dream the status
the lifestyle money
quick money money yeah yeah and it's uh
it's a shame actually
interesting yeah i think there's
something success stories out there that
actually people go from rags to riches
in
mlm you know that's what the whole
industry is based on there's a there's
a lot of bs i'll be honest okay there's
a lot of bs
you know i i drive this car i live here
like how you do with
dan lok and everybody else
you know but there's also real people
that actually do make the actual numbers
and uh no i have never disagreed that
people aren't making real money but my
question is where's that money coming
from
is it because they're selling so much of
a legitimate product or is it because
they've got such a base of people
underneath them constantly buying and
thinking that they're gonna be
just like a guy and so what i would say
is if you're making the money off the
backs of
other dreamers that's a scumbag way to
make money but
i mean other people say look i i get it
i and
i'm not here to rail against multi-level
marketing we're here to talk about this
ponzi scheme specifically but i i've
always find it
hard to keep my opinions on this kind of
stuff uh quiet
because i do feel very strongly about
multi-level marketing and i think
i think it should be regulated way more
heavily in the u.s i mean or outright
banned because i think
yeah in the us now um you need to have
at least 50 of your people uh as
consumers of the product you cannot have
more than 50 percent
buying the product because they're
getting paid for the product but don't
you think that those numbers are
kind of rigged a little bit by the
companies
well i mean okay let's put it this way i
mean we got companies that donate
to the democratic party
okay i mean bill clinton was on amway's
big
extravaganza uh-huh okay uh
katie devos is now donald trump's uh
financial
they're so plugged into the to
politics political money that they put
in is huge
okay i mean mwa is here and the rest are
all way down here let's put it that way
okay and it's it's it's a huge industry
i mean we're talking 780 billion the
last count
i had mlm is huge
yeah mind-blowing it's
mind-blowing ponzi schemes are
probably bigger though ponzi schemes are
big records
they're making a lot of money per year
they make a lot yeah
real quick too so a lot of our little
more russian based
russians i've noticed a lot of europeans
going into this game
a lot of europeans want some easy money
and they trick everyone because people
hear
european accent they think oh that guy's
trustworthy they think he's like john
oliver or something like that
that's what americans think they think
as soon as they hear a european accent
they go oh this guy must be smart
well bit connect was american by the way
you know
yeah do we we hold an l i mean we hold
an l for bit connect i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna pretend that we're perfect
either okay obviously we do our
fair share of scumbag behavior uh
but um hey man it's been great talking
to you
thanks for coming on the show thanks for
having me on and uh hope
this can help some people make the right
decisions when they
think about investing yes and don't
throw good money after bad money
i mean i think that was like that was a
huge mistake to go into the sec
obviously hindsight's 2020. i get it i'm
not trying to you know
make you relive this but the idea of let
me go make my money back real quick
seems like it's always going to be a bad
choice it's like being on the rebound
you know trying to find the next
girlfriend after you get dumped by the
previous one
fair enough okay thank you thank you man
thanks mark
appreciate your time
wait wait sorry guys sorry guys we gotta
come back into this show
because we were off air and then you
started telling me that there's another
thing you're looking into something
called cuba tech now
that's offering less money but it's kind
of it is kind of a hype still
sort of yes but they have a little bit
more
real base for their making profits and
there's some things that'll make so that
they won't fail as fast
wait so wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on hold on what do these guys do
can you tell me about them
basically they do uh trading based on
artificial intelligence and they had
quantum computer
uh trading as well okay okay
so that's how they generate profits and
uh
how much are they saying they're gonna
make you per day about one percent per
day
about one percent per day so that's 30
per month but
they they do less than one percent
probably 25
per month but they keep paying you until
you get 250 percent
so if you put in 10 000 you get 25 000
around 10 months later but you'll get
daily payments of one percent
so why i
started this one is because uh they have
some
things that i like is one is that
we put our money in in bitcoin but
it's managed in u.s tether are you
familiar with tether
there is one tether is always one dollar
so it doesn't fluctuate like bitcoin
going up and down so alcor
failed when it went up like 20 when
bitcoin went 20
they just couldn't pay it i i believe
that's one of the reasons
so it it's stable it's always
one to one and when you take out your
interest it's in bitcoin
so you can take it to your wallet okay
another thing is that
uh they can adjust the amount of profit
you make per day and aquarius was like
if they said two percent it was like two
percent per day
and they had to pay that every day okay
so that's
a formula for failure another thing is
that
i've done zooms with the ceo the
marketing director
uh the master distributor and
also there's a big team of uh directors
that i will be on uh zoom
next week uh to really see that this is
actual
ai computing and quantum computing so
they also rent out their license
that they have a patent on for the
quantum computing and
that's also a base for
the income so there's less chance for
this to fail because they have more outs
in poker we say outs you know they can
adjust do you think that this is another
ponzi scheme though
it could be it could be you know but
if it is they're really putting
themselves out there into the public
and normally ponzi seems they don't want
to do that like my guy alex he had a
face mask on
and did
oh it's q u b i t e c h yeah
so i now find it i've been trying to
find this website i finally found it
um but but but let me tell you i mean
let me give you a quick
prophecy here because i'm going to go
out on a limb here
okay say that there is absolutely
ah i'm a hundred percent certain that
this
is a hundred percent another ponzi
scheme that you're getting into
and i find it fascinating that you're
like that you've gone
from one coin delcor
to outdoor now you're doing cubatech
stop
dude you're addicted to it
you said i don't know why these people
are promoting these like fixed rate of
returns
and instead of promoting a product but
it's because people
are falling for it right like that's why
yeah and you're one of them yeah i fall
for it
as well uh because uh well okay there is
robotic trading
okay and this is not yes but they're not
making one percent a day though
oh well just like it's just like the
bookie thing it's just like the bookie
thing
it's like a convenient excuse because
they use something that sort of happens
to justify why they're making so much
money but
right he's got nobody's making one
percent a day and if they are
they would never share it with people
why would they give you one percent a
day
they could just keep it you know how
easy it is if you can consistently make
one percent a day to grow a gigantic
trading uh
uh like what trading pool
it's not always one percent it's
sometimes
it doesn't matter 0.80 such an insane
return mark come on that's an
insane return you've got these hedge
funds full of a bunch of geniuses from
stanford struggling to make 20
a year and you're saying they're making
one percent a day
roughly well i mean
if you've done robotic trading um you
know 20
per month is not that difficult
sometimes okay it is possible all right
so i've i've done it you know and i've
actually taken out money and
mt4 you know and metaphor trading if you
if you look into
robots usually give 10 maybe 15
per month it's not it depends though i
mean
this is no no no no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no
would you say it's common to kind of
jump from one hype to another after they
blow up
yes actually in between alpha and
qubitec
uh there was a few that i jumped into
yeah and i lost
again you know some a little bit
there's there's heights we don't even
know about it's okay
okay okay mark you're killing me more in
between
you you have you have withheld the lead
this whole time
okay so you run us through the actual
gamut of
hypes that you've been in so you were in
one coin and then
and then it was alcor then what was it
uh for four eyes
before i died the day i put it in
actually died
okay yeah what um then
there was uh
called lebronic that gives 2.4 per day
which is still going actually i still
have that one um
and i did one that gives one it gives
20 every hour
and that one did not i could not take
money out of that one
hang on hang on sorry i i accidentally
hit my mic out i was laughing
20 an hour yes
there's a lot like that oh my gosh
oh my gosh and what happened to that one
it didn't pay out yeah yeah
so so what is it can you because okay
obviously a lot basically all of these
have turned out to be scams in one way
or the other
you have to know at a certain point so
what's the incentive for you
are you actually making money on these i
mean are you kind of are you actually
making money and you're like because you
have this whole group
so are you actually some out with with
all the downlines uplines all that kind
of stuff are you ending up with money
through these um well let's put it this
way i did not lose
in in alcor like i made more than i put
in
um the other ones i lost
one coin as well i also made money okay
uh more than i lost otherwise i wouldn't
be here
today i'd be nine to five i'm
i'm 55. i'm not gonna do a nine-to-five
job because it's not possible sure
i'd be doing something else you know
could you could you retire at this point
i mean it seems like you have
quite a bit of money i could with less
costs but i live in japan which is quite
spendy
um we just moved to a new place you know
because we thought we'd do really well
in alcor and we already signed the
contract to
to move someone else somewhere else
but um you know
my my goal is to to get 35 000 per month
like your other guests you had per month
in passive income
and that the formula for that is
actually real estate i know that
you know but to reach that level of
you know income you need to have you
know several properties and i'm not
there yet
you know to be honest but i do want to
reach that you know
within hopefully this year
do you think that's realistic in the
time frame of a year i mean
how could you possibly grow your assets
that much i guess maybe
the answer is uh
i could make that money but what i'm
saying is i want to make you know
that money in you know real estate would
pass
passive income i have one two three or
four properties of three properties
and actually three are overseas about
six properties right now
some are not cash flowing but it it's
possible
yes let me know what you think about
this because i'm kind of
there's an interesting problem here
which is that it seems now
i didn't know you had made money with
alcor um it i thought you had lost a
bunch of money
um so it seems like you
lose money at the end when they take all
the money out but you've made more money
than you've lost because you're kind of
the leader of this group
now doesn't that perversely incentivize
you to keep going out and finding these
things where you can make a quick buck
but like
doesn't that hurt the people who are
following you
what do you think about that yeah so i
need to be really careful
is what i'm thinking you know i need to
be careful about the next
step when i do actually bring something
to them that it's really solid
i've learned my lesson you know
obviously you know obviously you don't
want to bring something to people that
you know is going to fail
you know it you want and we were really
you know believing in both of these
companies
to be honest i mean it's
yeah i won't lie to you it we really
thought this was real
i mean one coin or alcor
but but after seeing the pattern though
i do get how you could fall for it in
the first place
100 i totally get it but once you see
the pattern of
okay they create promises insane return
and if you just look at like
other investments nobody's paying out
this return
so you have to ask yourself what about
this opportunity is actually
making that much money and it seems like
the answer is always the only thing that
makes sense is it's a ponzi scheme
because ponzi schemes can always promise
those returns there's not really other
investments out there
uh that can rival that kind of oh we're
just gonna pay you one percent a day
so tell me what is it that like you're
consistently thinking that there's
actually an opportunity out there that
will offer you that
legitimately when it seems like every
all of your experiences are that these
keep being illegitimate yeah i mean
that's a good point i mean
you know obviously we want to find a
company that will last
i mean that will continue you know not
that we want to continue the ponzi but
we want the people to get their money
back they want to have
people have you know solid returns as
well i mean
hedge funds fail you know other
investments fail you know companies go
bust penny stocks i mean
you won't be right but they're they're
their organizational structure is not
built on
fraud like which is ponzi teams are
right so let me let me ask you would you
go into a ponzi scheme knowing it's a
ponzi scheme if you knew you could make
the amount of money that you need to
retire
uh not if i knew it was gonna hurt
people
that's for sure but what if you kind of
didn't know
and then but it's gonna make you a ton
of money and it's a good ponzi scheme
it's a nice sexy ponzi scheme with a lot
of return
a lot of percentages
well like i said if if i knew that from
the beginning
you know it i wouldn't let them let them
do it
okay okay and uh
let me ask you this what do you think
the chances are that cuba to cuba tech
is a ponzi scheme
um what are the chances it is
yeah like right now it like on your mind
not in
the abstract just in your mind if you
based on what you know what you've seen
of the founders all this kind of stuff
what do you think the chances are that
this is a ponzi scheme
um i don't want to call it a ponzi
scheme
because you know ponzi schemes are made
to to fail
from the beginning that's the definition
of it
you know albert ponzi created it that
way but there are companies that fail
okay and i don't think this is a company
that
is wanting to fail on purpose and just
take people's money and run
okay i feel it's it's a solid genuine
company with
actual management actual uh
you know leadership and management so
but you probably felt the same way about
alcor right up until they ran
so my question is not what do you think
the intentions of the founder are but
based on their
structure of paying out pretty i mean an
extraordinarily high
return uh per day what do you think the
chances are that it ends up turning out
to be a ponzi like if we remove the mask
the algorithmic trading the quantum
computing was all an excuse the same way
that betting was an excuse
and it actually was just a ponzi scheme
what do you think the chances are
just give me a number i mean i'm not
you're not caught to be clear you're not
calling it a ponzi scheme i'm just
giving you like give me odds
right if we had to bet today yeah on it
what would what would it be not ten to
one
that it's it's not you know okay so you
think there's like a ten percent chance
it's upon this game yeah
yeah okay interesting well
this has been fascinating i mean i i
think it's i
i really want to get to the heart of
what makes
these things be so chasable because that
is what i am finding
i'll say i got into a future net uh the
group of people who got their money
stolen and somebody said oh yeah
i've been here before i basically been
here with uh crypto ml
global mlms before and i was like wow
that's an ex
pretty exclusive club of you know things
what do you mean you've been here but
how many times have you been here
and so i realized that's when i realized
there are people who just go from one
of these to the next and i had never i
had never seen that before
but now it's making sense you kind of
just kind of are
chasing these high incomes because you
want to make a lot of money fast or
is it like no i want something that will
last to be honest you know i want to
something that will be here you know at
least five to ten years down the road
that's that's what
how we make money in mlm is that the
longer it lasts
you know the more people come in the
more money we make so we don't
want something that's just a quick fix
we want
to be honest if you made ten thousand
dollars in amway that's an achievement
you know it's really hard it's really
hard that's a company that's not going
to go away
you know something like that i mean
traditional mlm
but you keep going after these
money-making mlms
yes he's finally still in the finance
industry why
though why you're saying not to go into
it it's so funny because you're saying
like don't do it guys this is a big
mistake
and then you're telling me actually that
it you're still going into it
yeah because i'm trying to find
something that's safer you know and
that's that's real
this time because i'm a little bit more
knowledgeable about these
hypes okay hopefully this one is more
real than
the others but what makes it more real
than the others though
uh well the management you know actually
talking to the people being able to zoom
with them
uh you know seeing their vision actually
seeing the traders doing the training on
the platforms
um okay but all of that can be faked and
nothing about look we're doing a zoom
right now but that doesn't mean that you
know that like i'm an inherently
trustworthy guy
it just means that you've done a zoom
call with me yeah
no i mean it could be fake sure okay but
i mean
to go to that extent to to make
everything
you know fake is at that level
that you know i know right now about the
company it's
it'd be pretty hard to be honest i mean
they
they've got real traders they've got
real management people
so but i'm still you know
in the beginning phases i just started
like uh two weeks ago
why do you think they would offer you
such a high rate of return if they can
make that much
well in basic trading the more money you
have
the more you can make total profit from
from everything assuming your strategies
don't cap out at larger scale
but at the same time many investors are
completely happy with making 20 a year
so assuming they could make all this
money why wouldn't they just offer
everyone 10 a year
leverage the account to the moon like it
seems like they're targeting
a specific class of people who are
willing to believe
who want this one percent daily like
what i'm saying is even if they could
make the money
why would they give it back to the
investors it doesn't make any sense
yeah well you know
people use mlm and to to get
more money to do the trading i mean
obviously the
the cash basis from the investors and
that's basically
you know it's like a fund it's like a
hedge fund
no i get i totally get what you're
saying like they're they're offering it
to
lure investors to get more money to
trade with more money right to make more
money
but what i'm saying is that people like
legitimate institutional investors
are ponying up millions and billions of
dollars
just to make five percent more a year on
the stock market
right than the s p makes they put up
millions of dollars into these hedge
funds which as you pointed out even
those failed
so what i'm saying is is we're talking
about that's like for like a 20
return 25 return what i'm saying is it's
super easy to lure investors
with slightly better than average
returns so if this technology was
actually real and it could actually be
demonstrated
they wouldn't have to give away over 300
percent
returns a year or would you say they pay
out to 250 percent they wouldn't have to
give that much out
to lure investors so what i'm saying is
from an incentive standpoint
automatically it seems self-evident that
this technology
is not real because they're not
demonstrating it to real investors and
that's where you could really pull in
the real
investment money right like so they're
instead targeting a bunch of people who
understand
don't know that much about finance right
it seems to me much about trading yeah
right that's that could happen
as well you know i know a little bit
about trading and i know that you cannot
fake
you know actual trading and you know
finance account they show your your
actual binance account
and they show the trading on that
finance account and
you know they have a much more uh
you know transparency than alcor did you
know in this company
i see i see so that's kind of making you
think it might be a good opportunity
yeah okay well i won't grill you anymore
uh
yeah cross fingers but i wanted to thank
you for coming on and sharing
being so transparent and so clear i do
think this will help a lot of people i
really do i think
a lot of people i i think will get a
good um
good sort of education out of this see
this world because i don't think most
people know it exists
and um yeah thank you for coming on mark
i wish you all the best thank you so
much coffee
i hope cuba tech turns out to be exact
like
i hope it turns out to be legitimate i
just uh
okay i have my opinions on it so anyway
thanks for coming on the show okay yeah
absolutely
you know what what goes on and what
happens yeah i want to i want to hear
about it
okay super keep watching your channel
too appreciate it
[Music]
lean on
[Music]
comes along